hi I'm Greg hi I'm amber amber so a
couple weeks ago I'm half Filipino half
Italian more touching my Filipino side
these days
congratulations thank you I'm working on
a couple weeks ago I did a reaction to a
couple of these um this is restaurant
called Jollibee Filipino like fast food
place why do I know that because they
exist in California they do you like
boba tea right I might cut this part out
of the video because I don't know okay I
know them I saw these commercials and
they were so emotionally provoking for
our restaurant yeah and then I saw one
for road one that they shot for the
Philippines that made me cry again
Victoria beret said you should react to
the breeze Philippines a good experiment
commercial you're gonna make me cry I
don't know if you're gonna cry
okay we might just be like really
touched all I know it's Filipinos tend
to get emotional during the red well I
can tell I'm learning so much today okay
I'm ready
[Music]
oh my goodness
Allah Allah and Allah will forgive me I
only buy maybe pass the glass
oh but thank the maker mommy she says no
she's like no people living in our oh my
god
the girls love it they're like yeah
somebody needs everything
I only might have been in diamond that's
enough oh nothing
my topic is not and we don't talk bad
about your child is their dirty average
experiment
[Music]
all those kids are helping out we had
you drilling any hero compete hero today
yeah girl that's my girl how I will be
actor here
[Music]
my boss often
[Music]
hahahaha oh my god
[Music]
oh she's crawling it's down to her chin
oh we're happy old man hold on well
let's see we witness witness
ah yeah in regards to doing the news
like oh you know hi Tina
my photographer brows I'm going home on
every experiment a secret or she knows
it
she's like okay girls new person yes
girl you are judged him wrong you have a
good old boy what you're not right here
to wash away thing that it is to bring
up a good child green hairy trees yes
because Franz is a detergent or
something
what's a detergent I think so hey wells
in that smart wow that was a really
beautiful laundry detergent campaign run
experiment
actual love tend to get to me oh it's
like a Filipina keep nickimja tear of a
oh man I really got through I didn't
know I needed a Filipino a child until
just now but those are actually like
feel-good tears
because normally I like rice commercial
them like this was like oh yeah good a
Turner they always start they tend to
start out they tend to be about
something in school and then when it
starts off it's like okay where's this
going it really pulls you into like I
don't know what's going on quite yet and
then when they reveal yeah what can
happen Eames that revealed I couldn't
just get back in your heart that's like
ah really touching me
oh it was so sweet I wonder if they like
got the school to volunteer them for
that she did all the footage of the kids
who didn't help I would love to see that
they should show just walk box ah yeah
it's only just a bunch of white kids a
why kids in the building
yeah nope not going to help your mama I
saw you at me Emily here isn't my
parents of a child I don't wanna be no
wise imagine Alan should shoot kids they
were really cute one of the little girls
will go making my sister was my sister
is younger
really
my heart brain yeah the cutest when
Filipino women cry always thinking my
mom whenever I've seen her cry you know
it breaks my heart mom doesn't cry and
when she cries she's like drama she's
fighting oh good god it's like it's like
she know you're sorta for ya and she
just can't hold it to happy ass so
whenever I see someone cried it just
kind of led to my mom a little bit ah I
wonder if it if I when I was thinking
when I was a kid I would have done
something to help out like that I was
yeah I was not afraid to talk to anyone
was a pretty concern either you been how
stupid amount of times I've been kidding
me matt has bled me to bed but no you're
just you see someone needs help when
you're a kid you're like oh cool and
you're and you don't even think twice
about it yeah you just you just want to
help
yeah the mud room 530 mud doesn't bother
you now I'm fancy and I would not do
that I gotta admit I mean is we just
gonna like totally kill the vibe this
whole video but all the dialogue at the
beginning
sounded like a dirty sex talk that you
would hear some people having as adults
it was not there's no dirty baby why are
you it's all about how you're very baby
let me help you clean up there on one
line I read or I like the sounds like a
sex book you are being naughty but now
you're not what it was this weird what
it is very fancy kids I feeling so what
they would have said is what happened
thank you I didn't do that because then
that gives away the reveal why are you
so dirty yeah this is like what all my
excellent you're so dirty so is there
any way to wash them you'd be the one to
watch that ball this is a whole new take
on this video yeah you're so dirty baby
yeah he just gave me the lime without
any of the concavity yeah no context
that I have to just interpret it every
like oh they're having a sex talk
clearly they are having us I mean I
would have never read that and been like
oh there's like little Conrad mother and
daughter
never known but besides my perverted
American interpretation of a few lines
of dialogue I was a very touching
commercial I love how your perverted
side is American but your loving side is
Filipino yeah I know how to tailor my
emotion to determine this video right -
Americans all good things Filipino
relate and right I'm saying it get
subscribers how you do the work
how you do the Lord's work they do the
Lord's work in Filipino send any
Christians Oh doing it so cool I'm from
the south where we're all Christians yes
so two southerners in America Filipinos
are not far parted yeah their pregnancy
the same personality I love that they
had boys and girls both helping I
thought that was really sweet because I
think a lot of times you would think
that a little girl like wouldn't be able
to get in the mud and help pick things
up I do that was really cute that they
got to experience almost nice true girls
getting dirty I'm outside Todd let's
[ __ ] talk about children amber commits
eluding is really dangerous I leave
quotes to Luke and subscribe yeah I'm
getting a flag at all things in a way
that I never want to be flagged for so
we're going to stop that conversation
yeah correcta the real rejects subscribe
to my channel subscribe to amber
platform and amber faster I promise it's
not this weird
yeah I had my co-host from afterbuzz TV
Renee Ariel who does a dating advice on
YouTube okay and we realized we both
must be in Star Wars so she was my my
guest for my Star Wars react series I'm
going to be doing another react series
for resident evil
Wow and I'm going to be having a new
youtuber on to review those with me why
not about it ah I want to do it one with
you I just don't know what the next
series is going to be okay whatever ever
I have set you I don't know if you know
in your razor I didn't think about that
until now but now that you say that you
jokey yeah
thank you for the problem I'm sorry I
shouldn't love it my tongue and I wasn't
sure what it was
videos are bright today yeah i am i
throwing off your wife judy really
really well idea